[Musique]
bien oui vous l'avez deviné ce soir la
dernière séance en visite à nos cousins
belges
et pour fêter l'événement et faire trois
rtb on vous présentait une grande
première ce sera un film en relief qui
va donc présenter maintenant par la voix
d'or du cinéma de minuit de fr3 j'ai
nommé monsieur patrick brion c'est le
fils qui parlent se réfère 3 et léguer
un
c'est en 1958 que le réalisateur richard
temps rencontre à elvis presley ou je
vous en prie de poterie pour depuis
plusieurs semaines vous suivez donc deux
émissions vous devez tout ce matin être
en possession des lunettes nécessaires
voilà un très bien il va très bien
parfois un gros nez tout fonctionne bien
bon maintenant voici le seul élément
sérieux du trio bertrand tavernier qui
me suis tourné à tâtons dans coup de
torchon normale d'un film noir puis
c'est un bon point pour une émission
d'avant jamais bien peur maintenant
alors à 20h30 vous allez voir l'étrange
créature du lac noir
jack arnold sa wii dont c'est un film
dont un critique et télé cinéma disait
que le monstre était très soignée sur
lui et
très bien soigné aussi la présentation
c'est tout
on va tenir les fm j'ai dit oui alors
donc soyons sérieux à 20h30 à 20h30 donc
la dernière séance sur fr3 et sur rtd
vous présentera un film de jacques
arnold en relief de fait si l'étrange
créature du lac noir et à 22h45 un film
de michael curtiz avec un esprit slec
king créole
[Musique]